we're gonna do something today that we
don't usually do today's cancellation is
going to be something of a sequel to
yesterday's on Wednesday as you know we
talked about the issue of high body
counts specifically we discussed why men
care about a woman's body count how many
men she slept with and why it's valid
for us to care about it and why in fact
we should care about it we're not going
to rehash that topic we can go back to
yesterday's show and listen or find the
clip on YouTube that segment got a
pretty big reaction and as they say
sparked a conversation many people both
men and women agreed with the points
that I raised some disagreed and then
there was
as expected a loud minority of people
who who didn't disagree necessarily with
the substance of my remarks but who
nonetheless had a problem with the focus
of my remarks I spent most of the
segment talking about why women
shouldn't have high body counts
but why didn't I say more about why men
shouldn't have high body counts so let
me read a few of these comments and
messages and I think this is a
representative sample Matt you dropped
the ball on the body count rant
everything you said about what women's
body counts is true but it's just as bad
for men who have high body counts it's
just as much of a red flag you can't let
men off the hook another says Matt Matt
says nothing about men having a high
body kind of just as bad for men to have
a high body count and all the negative
things he said uh women having to buy
about a high body count apply to men
this one-sided conversation is stupid
another says number one the association
between STDs and sexual experience is
valid for both men and women number two
the argument about habit of following
carnal desire holds both for men and
women number three as for moral and
values only women's morals values are
called into question number four desired
self-control dignified and classy are
attributes that pertain only to women ah
new exciting Logic for them uh for
redneck University another says I concur
with every Point made with one caveat
this conversation shouldn't be about
women's body counts it should be about a
partner of either gender another says it
needs to be acknowledged that a high
body count is just as disgusting in men
as it is women men who are virtuous and
Chase should also be the one sought
after two uh another says of course the
misogynist who wishes that he was still
in the 1940s focuses his whole body
count diatribe on women
also both men and women should care
about body count not just men caring
about a woman's account it's kind of
gross on both parties do you like being
used and finally Matt I get tired of
constant hyper focus on criticizing
women that's why women become defensive
Society holds women to a higher standard
while painting men as the victims
okay so let me make a few points about
this
first anyone who listens to the
monologue knows that I did in fact
stipulate at the end that obviously it's
bad for men to be promiscuous also most
of the same reasons apply a promiscuous
man has likely been exposed to to and
possibly contracted any number of
disgusting diseases a promiscuous man
lacks self-control lacks virtue lacks
self-respect lacks dignity and so on
and I did State this in the monologue
but of course the caveat that I offered
there was ignored by the people who were
determined to Come Away with the
impression that I was being somehow
unfair and sexist towards women and I
think for those people
the moment I entered into this
conversation uh they had already
determined that like they had already
determined that no matter what I say it
has to be sexist
second did I spend equal time explaining
why high body counts are bad for men
well no I didn't
and why well because that's just not
what the conversation was about
the point was specifically to explain
why men care about high body counts and
that's been the debate in society and
it's what I was weighing in on not
everything has to be equal all the time
okay just because we spend a certain
amount of time talking about one group
of people that doesn't mean that we need
to give equal time to the other group
neither should we generalize every
conversation so that everything is about
everybody and no group is ever
specifically singled out
the demand for this kind of thing is
it's immature and it's silly and it's
childish
it's the sort of thing I deal with as a
parent
you know it's like when my kids are
upset because a sibling got a slightly
bigger piece of pie for dessert
I'm not going to sit there with a ruler
and measure it all out exactly precisely
equally sometimes you get the bigger
size sometimes you get the smaller
slides that's life not everything is
equal and when you insist on that kind
of equality it's not because you care
deeply about fairness and Justice it's
because you're being selfish and
small-minded
third the idea that Society is harsher
and more critical towards women is
simply wrong in fact it's delusional and
laughable
and yet it's a narrative that you hear
from people on the left and the right
you know it's not that Society
criticizes women more
it's that in the last few years
society's some some segments of it
anyway
have started criticizing women at all
you see for a long time nearly all of
the lecturing all of the holding
accountable
all of the criticism was directed
towards men and that has started to
shift ever so slightly in recent times
and the people who preferred the old way
are reacting as though women have been
entirely villainized they haven't
even with a slight uptick in criticism
still the group most often demonized
most often blamed most often cast as the
villains are men specifically white
straight men
they're still the subject of most of the
scolding most of the finger-pointing
most of the scapegoating
it's just that recently we've started to
hear on occasion people speak up and say
well well here's what women are doing
wrong and here's what they need to do
better too
see men men have been hearing this
message forever from everywhere
women are not used to hearing it
certainly not so directly and bluntly
for a long time you just never you would
never hear anyone stand up and say women
need to do this better
you especially whenever here any men men
say that
even though again on the other side of
it
for years women were lecturing men that
way all the time
so now uh a little bit of that's going
in the reverse and we're acting as
though it's only ever goes in the
reverse which is not the case
now fourth one of the reasons why it's
necessary to specifically state that
women shouldn't be promiscuous is that
on the other end there are powerful
cultural voices claiming that female
promiscuity is an objectively good thing
the institutions in our country are
heavily invested in the narrative that
it's empowering for women to become
sexually liberated and sleep with
whoever they want whenever they want and
this message doesn't really go the other
way there isn't nearly as much of a push
to encourage men to be promiscuous and
you certainly don't hear anyone ever
claiming that uh that it's empowering
for a man to have sex with lots of women
like when's the last time you ever heard
that what's the last time you ever heard
someone say that a man who's had sex
with a lot of women is empowered
it doesn't happen
in fact I'm not sure if I've ever heard
anyone say that it's liberating for men
to have sex with lots of women that kind
of encouragement only goes one way which
makes it especially important to
counteract and speak out against it
this is the way it goes in modern
society certain types of sins committed
by certain groups of people are
specially promoted and encouraged and it
then becomes necessary for those of us
on team sanity to specially denounce
those sins because they are being
specially celebrated when it comes to
carrying your valuables or self-defense
items in your vehicle most people feel
that they have to choose between safety
and convenience someone breaking into
your car typically typically going to
check the glove box under the seats
under the center console now we can
outsmart them with the headrest safe
which gives you convenience and peace of
mind hand rest safe is exactly what it
sounds like you can replace your
standard headrest in your car with their
easy to access safe to access the safety
just pull the side part off and then you
can either use your fingerprint use a
key or manually type in the code to open
the save there's no way that anyone
could know your headrest safe is even
there even if they did there's no way
they could get it open without using one
of the three methods to unlock it
Pandora safe has a universal design that
allows it to fit all vehicles the best
part is these come in a variety of
colors to make the interior match the
interior of your car I have their black
leather Vulcan headrest for my vehicle I
love it depending on the day I'll put my
self-defense items cash or medication in
the safe keeps me gives me peace of mind
knowing that it will stay out of the
hands of our kids valets or Intruders so
what are you waiting for Save 100 today
at the headrestsafe.com with promo code
wall should check out that's the
headrestsave.com promo code Walsh
Fifth and finally
is it bad for men to sleep with lots of
women as established already the answer
is yes obviously
is it just as bad
yes in the sense that licentiousness is
morally disordered is sinful and no
matter who's engaging in it That Remains
the Same
but is it just as much of a red flag in
other words is it just as troubling of a
sign when a man has a history of
sleeping around as it is when a woman
has a similar history
the answer there is no it isn't still
bad for men men should not behave that
way yet it isn't exactly the same
this is the part of the conversation
that of course will be misconstrued by
the legions of morons who are determined
to misconstrue it but it's worth saying
anyway a high body count for a woman is
indeed more of a red flag than it is for
a man it's a red flag for both
but the flag is a bit bigger a bit bit
brighter flies a bit higher with women
and there are many reasons for this I
think most of this is like intuitive I
think people just understand this
but but I'll mention one
is it men are less emotional by Nature
we form fewer attachments and we form
them more slowly so that makes it easier
for a man to come compartmentalize it's
easier for him to take a more practical
utilitarian view of something even his
relationships men are also more visual
in their attraction we're attracted to
looks more than women are obviously
it'll help a man attract a woman if he's
a good looking guy but even if he has
average looks even if he's like ugly
he can make himself more physically
attractive to women by being confident
by being personable by being funny by
being successful
now an ugly woman will have a harder
time overcoming that deficit with
personality alone because a man's
initial attraction is based much more on
visual cues I mean it's based almost
entirely at least initially on visual
cues
all this means that that a man's wiring
makes it easier for him to have casual
sexual relationships doesn't make it
that doesn't make the behavior good it
doesn't make it any less sinful
it doesn't make it quote natural it just
means that it's an easier habit of
behavior for a man to fall into
women on the other hand are wired to be
more emotional to be more affectionate
to be more easily attached less driven
by raw by raw physical visual attraction
and this makes it a sign of Greater more
severe moral disorder when a woman has a
high body count in other words
she shouldn't even really be tempted to
act that way
like a life of casual sex should be more
immediately and innately unappealing to
her as a woman
this isn't even a Temptation that she
should really have and so if she's
living such a life it speaks potentially
to a deeper and more serious problem
now there are plenty of examples like
this that go the other way like for
example
it's not good when women are overly
sensitive when they're quick to take
offense when they have poor control over
their emotions it's not good for women
women shouldn't be that way you know uh
but it's worse when men are that way bad
for both worse for men because it's a
behavior that is even farther from the
masculine ideal than it is from the
feminine
it should be easier for a man to not to
behave that way because that's not how
he's wired or at least it's not how he
should be wired
that's why when a woman is too sensitive
and she cries too much and she takes
things too personally men find it
annoying
you know it's annoying
but when a man is too sensitive and he
cries too much and he takes things too
personally women find it repulsive such
as annoying it's disgusting it's like
nauseating for for a woman to see that
from a man
that sort of thing can be so like just a
matter you know you'll see sometimes a
woman will like break down in tears
because she's just very frustrated very
frustrating day and she starts to cry on
the other hand like imagine a man
breaking down in tears you're asking
what's wrong I don't know I'm just so
frustrated such a frustrating day I'm
just overwhelmed and he's crying
now whatever we hear from society about
a man should be more emotional I
guarantee almost every woman sees that
and they're not attracted to that man at
all that's gross like get it together
that sort of thing could be a deal
breaker from a woman's perspective
from a man's perspective when a woman
acts that way you know it's not really a
deal breaker
the behavior is bad for both groups but
it's but for one it's more disgusting
it's more of a red flag
it's it's not just a flaw for a man to
be weak and teary and overly sensitive
it is specifically a feminine flaw
feminine flaws in men are always going
to be worse than feminine flaws in women
on the other hand it is a flaw for women
for a woman to be crude and vulgar and
to run around hooking up with random
people and taking pride in her sexual
Conquest
but even worse it is a masculine flaw
and masculine flaws will be more
repulsive in women than they are in men
that's the Nuance here
easy to misinterpret easy to take out of
context and accuse me of saying things
I'm not saying but it is what it is
and those who deny this innately obvious
point
are there for today canceled
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code walls
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there